this is not my never parishes it is born
of you in a cycle
I was like you big disparity they are
eternally bound to mr. purpose an
incarnation doing them to honor that
cell to sea of darkness for all time
demise the literal demonic incarnation
of hatred has maliciously stained the
land of Hyrule in blood for what
purposes hatred burns so brightly we
don't know and may never fully
understand but his hatred has for
millennia plagued the innocent people of
Hyrule time and time and time again in
the game ocarina of time the skulls of
the shadow temple whisper to link that
here is gathered high rules bloody
history of greed and hatred Ganondorf
himself upon his own demise at the end
of the game Twilight Princess says to
Link and Zelda to not think that this
ends here the history of light and
shadow will be written in blood in
breath of the wild we see that this
cycle of hatred and blood is a well
known and accepted fact impass states
that the history of the royal family is
also the history of calamity Ganon a
primal evil that has endured over the
ages zelda also says that Ganon is a
pure embodiment of the ancient evil that
is reborn time and time again it is
obvious that the legend of zelda is a
stained one a painful bloody malicious
one that appears to never be able to
find true peace it is scarred terribly
and for what is there to be no end to
the cycle why is the curse unbreakable
evil Rises the hero's defeated it rises
again the hero's defeated again but what
is the point to all of this for many of
the answer to these questions is divine
after all who set these events in motion
who allowed this terrible evil to ravage
the light countless times over countless
years it is none other than the
goddesses themselves
[Music]
the creation of the world surrounding
Hyrule happened thousands upon thousands
of years ago when the three goddesses
din farore and nayru decided to make the
world we see today in the Legend of
Zelda we learned from the great Deku
Tree and ocarina of time that din the
goddess of power cultivated the land and
created the red earth thus forming the
geography of the world Nehru the goddess
of wisdom poured her wisdom on to the
earth and gave the spirit of law to the
world formulating the physical sciences
and furore the goddess of courage
produced all life forms who would uphold
that law since their creation story
holds no gaps or room for imagination we
must then assume that everything we see
in the Legend of Zelda was indeed
created willingly by the goddesses
themselves this means that the father of
evil the original demon king demise
himself would have had to have been
created by the goddesses who knew he
would rise to betray his creators after
all it was from within the earth itself
that he and his armies arose in Skyward
Sword we see that one dark fateful day
the earth cracked wide and malevolent
forces rushed forth from the fissure why
did the goddesses make demise why did
they leave behind the omnipotent
Triforce as a relic destined to incite
greed and violence and murder why did
the goddesses invent evil and does that
make the goddesses themselves evil in
ancient Chinese mythology the yin and
yang symbol is a representative of a
belief that out of a perfect balance of
perfect opposites a world can exist
north and south male and female light
and dark and good and evil are all
opposites to one another that must
remain perfectly balanced to maintain
what we know as the world itself this
philosophy is apparent in many forms of
media across the world in the movie The
Incredibles the villain named syndrom
states that as part of his master plan
he would sell all of his inventions at
he's had his fun with them so that
everyone can be super and when
everyone's super no one will be this
implies the foundational truth that
without opposition variety cannot exist
and without variety his life really
alive other forms of media like the show
Neon Genesis Evangelion explore this
question and conclude that variety does
indeed make living it worth it in the
end bringing this back to Zelda we see
the influence of this yin-yang
philosophy manifested in characters
quotes and even the Triforce itself
albeit there are three sides that must
be balanced instead of just two at the
end of the game Twilight Princess Zelda
states two Midna that shadow and light
are two sides of the same coin one
cannot exist without the other
it is apparent that the world of Zelda
is born from this concept of balance and
therefore we can conclude that the
goddesses in creating demise created a
necessary evil
that would essentially spur the world
into life it should be noted that the
goddesses never actually allow evil to
triumph in the end this was represented
as well by the fact that there are two
chosen of the goddesses to combat the
one evil individual evil is always
outnumbered knowing all this and after
discussing the philosophy behind it let
us ask once again what is the point or
purpose of The Legend of Zelda
[Music]
the answer is simple life is the answer
the goddess has created a world that
will spin on with the light and darkness
continually keeping another in check and
therefore will create variety diversity
and meaning this is not without
consequences however as we see when
demises malice is allowed to run free
lives are taken and lands are ripped
apart leading once again to the rise of
the hero and hialeah to quell the evil
and restore peace to the land but will
evil ever be finished once and for all
will the hero one day be unnecesarry
will Haile ever leave the world of
mortals in my opinion I don't believe so
but who knows what the future holds for
The Legend of Zelda what's the point
well here it is
save Hyrule as many times as it takes
[Music]
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed the video please consider liking
it as this really helps the channel out
in more ways than you know and if you
haven't subscribed yet but also want
some more juicy Zelda content subscribe
away and hit that Bell for more
top-notch Zelda stuff to come I know
this was more of a serious video
covering more philosophy than normal so
please comment below letting me know if
you like the sort of video and want to
see more in this fashion or just comment
letting me know what you think in
general huge thanks once again to my
patreon supporters and to the artists
behind my beautiful new channel art drop
by our discord server to say hi that's
all I've got for you so as always have a
great rest of your day peace
[Music]